[Music]
today's question comes from lindsay in
albuquerque
we have ten thousand dollars beyond our
six months emergency savings and we
wanna help we want to use that to help
pay down our mortgage because we have no
other debt but with inflation we partly
feel the need to keep it in case
inflation gets worse
should we save it or put it towards the
mortgage thanks so much you have
inspired us to live like no one else
um
it's a great question i mean inflation
just came out to what 9.1
in june it went up higher than they were
even expecting and predicting um so it
is something obviously that's affecting
all of us we're laughing about the gas
earlier but groceries i mean all of it
the everyday necessities it's just gone
up and everyone's feeling it
and so i don't think it's enough
to not continue on the baby steps
because lindsay if you guys have an
emergency fund in place it may just mean
adjusting your monthly budget which is
not always fun and exciting but
where you are today i would do that and
continue to pay off the mortgage because
becoming debt-free and not having a
mortgage payment is going to free up
more monthly
to put towards that inflation uh and
towards your budget you know to all your
monthly expenses so i would continue to
put that ten thousand dollars towards
your mortgage because you have an
emergency fund very good
here's the thing
the ten thousand dollars anytime you
have a an ongoing chronic event
it's not a singular event it's going to
keep going
and you want to offset that
with a lump sum
that is always a recipe for mathematical
suicide
because you're going to burn the lump
sum and then you're screwed because you
never made any changes to adjust to the
situation yeah okay so example of that
is we saved up 20 000 my wife wanted to
quit and come home and
that 20 000 is going to make it okay to
not have her income
no it's not
because if you're burning through the 20
000 because your spending was at a level
higher than his income while she comes
home
when you burn through the 20 000 you're
screwed yep yep so that's a chronic
ongoing
serial event which is her income goes
away permanently
monthly we are underwater because we
made no changes and the lump sum made it
feel better until the lump sum is gone
right and that's the exact same thing
here okay let's talk about inflation for
a second can we because it continues to
rise
and what are you seeing when you're
looking out it's like okay because what
causes inflation you know we say around
here supply and demand and we can talk
about that more but but there's a lot of
a lot of people
pointing fingers a lot of different
directions you know biden saying well
the war in iraq and then
the war in ukraine and russia is causing
it uh people are saying well the fed
runs in the engine i mean there's
there's fingers pointing everywhere of
what's causing inflation and it
continues to rise it's not like we're
seeing it
yeah i don't know
like my personal opinion is that's a
lagging indicator the the cpi that that
most that it's not i mean this time next
year we're not going to be at nine
percent i just don't i really don't
believe it i predicted that we were
going to be here now a year ago you did
which is and but and i don't think we'll
be here now a year from now it'll be
better yeah being a lot better
and here's why there's three major
components to this inflation it is not a
white hot economy that caused the
inflation in the 70s we had a white hot
overheated economy
and it drove things crazy
coved
and by and large the pandemic the
economic suppression when we shut down
the world
we left entire gaps
in supply factories weren't making cars
factories weren't making lumber
factories weren't
services weren't being provided so we
left these huge gaps
and so we ended up with shortages in
everything
okay and we had supply chain problems we
started calling it because we couldn't
get stuff off the ocean it was sitting
in the bay at la and that kind of stuff
so all of those shortages anytime
there's a shortage of something it runs
the price up now that's smoothing out
okay for instance lumber went up triple
it was running about 500 a board foot
and then it went to 1700 a board foot it
went up triple and now it's back to
about 480 of board foot right now okay
so it's the factories caught up
to this the supply caught up through the
demand and the price came back and
normalized
same is happening with cars
used cars for the first time in the
history of mankind went up
you know they went up and the reason
they went up was there was no new cars
right and once new cars started hitting
the lots again the factory started
emptying the car car the car containers
right there on the lot boom boom boom
boom they start lining up on the lot now
you got new cars so that again that's
absorbing some of the demand there's
more supply so you could use cars are
coming back down
and they're going to start going down
again like they used to yeah okay so
we're seeing that part of the inflation
go away but it's not all gone yet and
it's still a component it's going up
it's still component of that okay
the the cpi is the consumer price index
okay that is the measure of inflation
and that's the measure of goods and
services and they've got it weighted
meaning that the things that you spend
the most on have the bigger portion of
creating that nine percent
okay so uh the things that you spend the
least on actual dollars okay so for
example housing
is an element of the cpi well obviously
in all of our budgets most people's
budgets that have a house payment
housing is the biggest line item in your
budget so it's the biggest portion so as
long as housing is going up
your cpi is going to go up
so housing goes up a little
bread and
milk and uh eggs and cheese and crackers
and all that stuff everything but look
at the number of dollars you spend on
that versus the number dollars you spend
on housing right if that goes way down
and housing goes up you're still going
to see inflation okay okay
but if housing goes down
and
housing values housing values the prices
go down the values go down and milk and
bread doubles
you might not even see inflation because
the house price going down might might
so the housing market has caused all
this inflation drives a lot of it is
what i'm saying okay and energy's the
other one energy the the cost of the
pump that's what's killing us and that
one is a political issue
that's not an economic issue that was
created by biden shutting it off to go
green
and we did that created a tremendous
shortage and it's doubled our gas prices